[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who's been using gorilla
glue on his hair in anticipation for
godzilla vs kong
the monster movie is releasing at the
end of march and there's a lot we need
to talk about in regards to the film
we have a new leaked trailer the first
look at mechagodzilla has been revealed
through the toys
there's some brand new screening details
and a lot more
bold spoilers ahead so if you don't want
anything potentially ruined then i
recommend that you turn off now
make sure you smash the thumbs up button
if you'd smash godzilla's face in with
an axe
and don't forget to subscribe if you
hashtag team kong
shout out to everyone who's already left
the video thank you
all my congress who have remained now
let's get into it
okay so sorry for going off a bit there
now mechagodzilla yeah
he is gonna be in the movie i know it
you know it
your boy who doesn't even like spoilers
already spoiled it for himself
and everyone across the globe knows it
as a universal truth
for weeks we've been waiting for a first
look at the character
and slowly the merchandise has started
to come out that shows him in a lot more
detail
firstly we have a look at the upcoming
funko pop and the character
which has him seeming quite similar to a
terminator in many ways
i love this skeletal body and also the
red eye balls
and it definitely calls back to the
james cameron classic
in my opinion hashtag team mechagodzilla
now whilst funko pops are a bit
difficult to gauge how things will look
in the film
we also have a brand new image of an
action figure on its side
you can see that it has a bright red
line along its fin as well as a giant
tail that carries this along too
i'm guessing that this will power up at
some point in the film
and that it will shine as mekaji
unleashes his own version of the atomic
breath
there's also a big box on top of his
wrist which i'm guessing
may carry missiles or weaponry in it and
overall it's a pretty awesome looking
action figure
mecha g is gonna be working away in the
shadows as a big weapon
and i don't know how they're gonna sneak
him around without him being seen
but this first look is definitely
awesome
now there have been several trailers
posted recently as well
and i actually uploaded one last week
just before the one division finale
some of you caught it but for whatever
reason warner bros blocked it
and at the moment i've got a copyright
strike on my channel
yay in a panic i deleted every trailer
upload i'd posted
just so they couldn't hit me with
multiple claims and i actually lost 12
million views
in the process which wasn't a fun day
i'll tell you that however
i spoke to real rejects about it who got
hit with something similar
and apparently this is because it was a
leaked trailer that warner brothers
don't want
out yet that's totally fair as i
shouldn't be posting things that are
meant to be seen by the public
but it was on youtube so i just thought
oh well it's clearly out now anyway
enough of my life story
why i'm telling you this is because i
want to discuss some of the things in it
but i can't show the images i'm talking
about purely because it's a leak
and the video might get blocked however
i do have the trailer saved on my laptop
so i can verify everything i'm talking
about it confirms a lot of the plot
and even has a glimpse at mechagodzilla
being reflected in godzilla's eyes
now it starts off with a g-dog swimming
into a city
and from here he unleashes an attack
this happens at night
so it's a completely different time to
the one that we saw in the first trailer
humanity doesn't know why this is
happening and thus they go on the hunt
for the legendary kong which takes them
to skull island
other details in it show godzilla
blasting kong with his atomic breath
while standing over him
and we also get a lot more of them
fighting underwater
during this bit they put some effect
over the music which makes it sound like
it's well well it's underwater but you
know what yeah it sounds really really
cool
i think the reason that warner brothers
are keeping a lid on it now is because
it clearly shows mechagodzilla reflected
in godzilla's eyes
and this likely confirms that the titan
defeats kong before facing off against
the mechanical monster himself
now this trailer is probably out online
somewhere and it might even be up on
youtube i just didn't want to risk it
after this strike
you might even see that that bit about
the eye being used as a thumbnail
if you search for it but i wouldn't be
able to confirm that as i'm
recording this before editing just know
yeah if you strike me down warner
brothers
i shall become even more powerful and
leak
everything i'll i'll leak the bloody
ending of the matrix i'll tell you
i also think that kong will end up
joining godzilla after this and the pair
will team up to take mechagodzilla down
but we'll talk about that more in just a
bit now why i want to hold off on that
is because we have some exclusive new
leaks from youtuber world of geekdom
who has clarified that this simulated
skull island is actually located in
antarctica
and this appears after kong is carried
across the sky the reason that they move
the titan to this remote part of the
world
is because godzilla is still going on a
rampage and wrecking up
shop we actually find out in the film
that godzilla is doing this because he
can still sense the presence of ghidorah
who we discover has been incorporated
into mechagodzilla
namely its brain at the end of king of
the monsters the head was of course
teased
and godzilla has been searching the
globe high and low not only for this
but the rest of its body parts which
have been scattered across the planet in
the south pole the humans are also
trying to find the entrance to the
hollow earth
which actually exists on this continent
this is where the titans originate from
and it's also the location where the
great war between the gojira and kaiju
was fought
apparently this is the place where kong
fashions his axe and he takes a giant
tree for the handle
and uses one of the gajira fins as the
blade it all ramps up to this fight in
hong kong which world of geekdom said
was the best battle in all of the
monster bits
it's a fully fleshed out fight that
doesn't divert to the humans
and just stays focused on the two titans
during this fight godzilla apparently
gets the advantage over kong
and the mechagodzilla appears now in the
fight mechagodzilla smacks kung away at
one point
and we as an audience are supposed to
believe that kong is actually dead
mechagodzilla whoops godzilla and is
about to kill him which is when kong
jumps back into the battle
according to the leaks we're really
meant to see that this is a completely
unstoppable machine
which juxtaposes godzilla who's
exhausted at this point from fighting
kong
because he's a living and breathing
creature godzilla is tired
whereas makaji can just keep going like
like the lads johnny
sins ask your dad about that now he has
him on the ropes and then kung
shows up behind him and smashes them up
which is when he and godzilla have a
stare down
but instead of fighting the pair part
ways the idea here is meant to be that
they have respect for one another
and that though kong lost he still saved
godzilla's life
so we as an audience can have respect
for him which
man i was i was team kong the whole time
bro
you know just let me down anyway after
hearing these i'm super excited for the
movie
i can't wait to watch it as i think it's
going to be something special
and the perfect way to end what is
probably going to be the best month i
can remember for a long time
not only have we had the one division
finale we've also got falcon in the
window soldier
snow piercer the flash superman lois
the snyder cut invincible and of course
godzilla versus kong
even before the pandemic i don't think
there was a month with this much cool
stuff in it
and having the big monster mash is the
perfect way to finish
march now obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on these updates so make
sure you comment below and let me know
as thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
show on the 31st of march in which we're
giving away three copies of a marvel 4k
box set of your choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the video the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the unanswered questions on one division
which will be linked on screen right now
we've cleared up a lot of the confusion
over the series so hopefully enjoy it
after this without the way thank you for
sitting through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace